what's your typical day like when you
get up in the morning what are you
devoting to acting and what are you
devoting to Trey and what are you
devoting to work outside of acting mmm
good question
how can I devote everything I think I'm
obsessed with it it's my obsession it's
my passion so really just for studying
things on TV other actors that I admire
or reading a lot scripts like what I
have been doing now I like to watch true
Hollywood stories behind the scene watch
people's other people's journeys of what
they have done to know that the rises
and falls doing this I will do a lot of
stage plays I love doing stage play it's
just the most organic part of acting
give me different other people when
everyone running like anything that's
dealing with the entertainment I just
love doing it so for me that's I'm
consumer so with that I really don't
take vacations because I can't enjoy it
because I'm not where I would like to be
feel like I need to be so if I'm on a
vacation so I'm still reading scripts
I'm still doing some researching I
remember the person was saying earlier
about going on actors access la casa
look at the breakdowns look just
everything that's in a backstage just
everything I just try to engulf myself
with as much information as possible of
the true Hollywood stories you've been
watching who is this very similar to
your own it's becoming Morgan Freeman
because it took Morgan Freeman thing he
didn't really get his break break and he
was like 44 he had done a lot of stage
acting in New York he was going back up
for everything's dried out whatever so
right now I'm at a pinnacle middle tier
like I just finished don't want to play
with a red of divine you want to hit me
and let us see a time nine-time Grammy
Award winner I didn't another play with
Kelly Price and and jackée so I'm on
that tier and
and I say so and I'm don't want to tell
my age it's not 44
well it's getting up there and so things
are starting to happen now getting a lot
of work now so I'm it's almost parallel
to tell him in a sense and he's
brilliant he's great so I'll take that
what keeps you motivated every day the
passion and the drive to say I was like
I told my my parents when I was leaving
to come out here I'm gonna die doing
this so there's nothing I can't accept
anything less than that even if I stay
at this level which I hope I won't I'm
still doing everything I I can I want to
do to pursue this you know as well as
called the pursuit of happiness
he's always pursuing something so I'm
pursuing this until you get to that
point and you still wanna because you
still want to continue to do more you
want to create more you wanna well I do
when I write my own projects and direct
and just own your own studio you can
green like I just love this were they
okay with that decision when you said
this is my this is what I want to do
with my life however it turns out they
will okay but they'll worry because like
anybody else you know the competition
and know that the chances are slim and
none and slim is already gone but they
know I've always been very responsible I
mean I was nationally Dean's List high
school college I've always lived in
Starr row and stuff like that so they
knew that it once I said my motto is
nothing to stop it regardless but they
have always been supportive to this day
so yeah
you